[Music]
my mom asked me to chop veggies
my mom asked me to chop veggies
are you going into town or anything
today i don't know
i don't know it's fine with me if we do
or
not that's why i just kind of
need to rest a little
yeah are you still feeling sick
um not really so much
like from not being able to breathe like
that was probably just when i exerted
myself it's just this poisonous just
wiped me out dang that's crazy
it's a little better believe it or not
there's some patches that are not like
crazy
cracked open today would you know how
you got it
i guess it's in my yard somewhere
because i i'm just mowing up all these
leaves and then it got dark and so i i
didn't see anything
but gosh yeah it runs in my family too
my dad had a horrible allergic reaction
and my son does too so oh really yeah i
was just talking to his birthday
oh yeah i had that for a month and so
uh yeah he was going to look up the
cream they gave him because he said it
really worked the prescription still
what they gave him the same uh
we call it like a prednisone it's a uh
it's a steroid and you take pills think
uh
actually it's interesting because i
mentioned that to somebody they're like
oh yeah you can use that for uh
you can use that for a high altitude it
opens up like i don't know
well maybe i'll get two for one out of
it
let's see if this needs to go
time okay i guess this is 36 minutes
that'll be about right because then
these towels
okay guys
um oh wait hold up so the way it's gonna
work is i'm chopping vegetables right
now so
you guys can just put any questions you
have in the chat
and i'll answer them to the best that i
can
so i'm trying to
okay
also i think this is misleading um i'm
not good at
chopping veggies oh my gosh babe
can i put you guys here let's see let's
see how it would work
oh no oh no no no we're gonna put you
back here okay
i thought it would work better
okay
there we go
okay
okay put that out
am i in england um so i'm living in
england but i'm
back in the u.s right now for a couple
weeks until
yeah just for a couple weeks though
until
i go back
january 6th i want to say
what's the worst food from england oh my
god probably something i've cooked
um the worst food from england
i haven't eaten out that much guys i'm
kind of cheap like i'm very
frugal i guess
so
yeah i don't really eat out much
okay um
what does my mom and dad think of kevin
samuels content um
okay so
i've shown my dad and my mom
some of it
i
[Music]
i think that my mom
okay i'm trying to think i would say
like they agree more with more than they
disagree i'd say where they disagree
it's like the high value men like have
options or like cheat type thing
um and
probably they're not really into the age
gap dating like i don't
my dad told me that so my dad thinks
differently than most people because the
way he thinks about it if you're dating
someone 20 years older than you then
you're not going to spend a good chunk
of your life in that with
a good chunk of your life with them
because like they're going to die sooner
and like
so if i'm 30 and i date a 50 year old
like
the stuff that we'd be able to do
together is just going to be very
different than if you date someone your
own age or
within 10 years
um so i'd say that's the two
biggest pieces that maybe they
differentiate at
um but i haven't showed them like a ton
of their content to be honest
um
let me see
like halving klein drip oh this is my
mother's i did not bring enough clothes
back
um from the uk
um
so
so
okay i don't even know if i cook veggies
correctly to be honest or chop them
i don't like vegetables
it's actually a problem i'm trying to
like them more but i just
they're just not that good
earlobes what that's such a weird
oh my gosh guys
so
um okay any other questions
no just earlobes okay
i'm chatting
i wish i had that genuine desire in me
to become a really good cook
i like cooking some things don't get me
wrong but
i'm just all about efficiency like i
could order
something
but
i am trying to be better
so let's see how tall am i six foot or
i'm just under i'm like five eleven and
a half
so if we're getting specific here five
eleven and a half
what's weird
about
being on the internet is like you have
so many people that you meet just like
randomly
that they they feel like they know you
but you don't really know them so
there's like
i don't know almost the level of comfort
that they have with you but you don't
have with them
so it's not necessarily a bad thing but
it's just it's hard to describe it
unless you've been in it before
uh
sometimes i think that god has favorites
and i think i'm the favorite i've been
thinking about this a lot
um
i literally was born into the best
family on the planet like
on top of that
i'm tall being tall is amazing i don't
care what anyone says about tall females
i love being tall i wouldn't trade that
for the world
and
i don't know i think about it i'm like i
think i'm god's favorite
because i get to go to all these cool
places
super young
that my parents pay for
like
i don't know how i could be unhappy
with this amazing of a life
to be honest
oh my gosh
um
so
how tall am i six foot
um
did you have to quarantine in the uk no
because i'm vaccinated
um
if i sketch something for you where
would i send it um you can send it to my
email just pearlythings gmail.com
you're a fan of me thank you um
i like tall girls to be honest do you
like tall guys or short guys
um i mean i think every girl
prefers taller guys but
for me it's always just been like
my height around or taller
um
i'm on the docklands campus yes i am
but the one thing that bothers me about
the manosphere is it's always
it's always such an equation for them
when it comes to like dating and it's so
much more complicated than that
like
it's not just like
you have all these qualifications and
women suddenly want you
um there's like common interests values
um
i don't know just like
chemistry
but a lot of times it's almost a
equation for
okay
okay
now we have different names for a reason
people are different yeah that's what
i'm saying like it's always
he
like i'll give you an example people are
gonna say i know i just know this is how
it's gonna go
that my ex
was very you know wealthy
um taller than me my type
and
so like leaving that relationship was a
mistake
and i know that it wasn't because
obviously
there are things that happen behind the
scenes i'm not gonna like
go into that but i know i made the right
choice
and
i just know the way the man of sphere is
going to look at it it's going to be
oh
why on earth would you do that but
you cannot
you cannot buy peace there's no amount
of money that will buy you peace
and
just my two cents okay
have i ever found bitter dating strategy
on reddit no
but you should send it to me
and just like
a lot of the stuff that guys
will talk about in this space is theory
and stuff they concoct behind their
computers
and i'm not saying there's no truth to
it but
i think a lot of times we lose touch
with reality
um okay
how do i leave it so the chat has to
stay up so i can see it
um
live chat all vegetables are visible oh
i'm cutting
peppers right now
but then i'm gonna chop onions so i
might cry
oh my gosh why does it go away
hopefully
but you guys can ask the different
questions and i'll give you my view on
stuff obviously
you know everyone has a different
opinion i you can take whatever you want
but
but you answer questions or ask
questions i'll answer them as honestly
as like i can you know
the one thing that's hard about being a
content creator is there's some stuff
you want to say
but you have to be
you know careful because you want to
maintain relationships
and not be like
disrespectful so to speak
um
would i go on a date with fresh no oh my
god
you guys
no no
oh god no okay
um
i like onions i usually okay what do you
think about guys that don't have or use
social media um i
so there's two theories i found about
this guys that don't use social media
on one hand there's like the nerdy guy
that doesn't like care about she didn't
care about all that stuff i really like
like in that
i really like it
but i think it leaves women with a sense
of
because some guys don't have social
media so girls can't find each other
and so especially if you met a girl
online or somewhere else like i think
it's going to cause her to be a little
more
suspicious
um
because
i don't know if that makes sense
because sometimes guys that don't have
social media
that don't have social media
but i think it's really attractive guys
that don't care about that stuff
i think that is very attractive
do i think that marriage will be around
in 50 years yes i do um will there be a
lockdown anytime soon
uh
probably
um maybe not a full block down but
they'll probably be more restrictions i
would guess
i'm hungry
oh gosh okay
um
there it is i'm gonna put a bowl
he's a bowl
um
how do you bring people down to earth
with dating standards
um
that is a hard one
um
oh gosh
i mean i i need more context who's the
person
you cannot bring someone you're trying
to date down to reality and dating
standards you you're not going to be
able to
give girls stats that you're interested
in and
and all of a sudden make them interested
in you i'll tell you one way not to do
it
um i think the best way to bring people
down to reality is
to
talk about it with the people that you
like love and care about
because i think the best way to change
the world is to like start with your own
so if you have any like close friends or
family members
um that you can have those conversations
with i think that's
probably the best way i would say
okay
um
do i think reality tv is reality um
okay i think reality tv is reality to
some extent um
i think that people do
you know fall in love and like have real
emotions on a show
but there's always going to be an
incentive to people
um
to
you know be a little bit more savage or
be a little bit more rude on tv because
you know it gets them views it gets them
clicks it helps them build a name for
themselves so
i think it's real but i do think people
exaggerate their personality a little
bit
um
okay
do i plan to have kids yeah i want um at
least two but i think i want four
i look tall i'm five eleven and a half
do i listen to rap on a day-to-day basis
now um
no no i still like country
no i definitely don't um
what do you think are the best places
for finding good woman oh gosh
um
okay um this is coming from my
experience this is gonna be a little
bias i
i think sports so girls that are
involved in like extra extracurriculars
um
so the gym
um
like i don't know a lot of people i know
met their significant other in college
like i think college is a great place to
find a wife
um
extracurriculars like there's beach
volleyball tournaments that go on every
weekend in your local town um
and those are primary that's a primarily
female sport
so if you pick up on a sport that's like
co-ed i think that's a great way to meet
girls um
i wonder if girls go to the library i
used to go to the library maybe a
library
where else
music so if you guys you know
like girls that are in
because i'm just trying to think of
where
different friends of mine
like girls that are super into music
like if you did music classes
anywhere that you can learn a skill i
would say actually anywhere you can
learn a skill would be a good place to
meet girls because
that shows that the girl isn't obsessed
with partying and isn't obsessed with
like
you know
validation and drinking and i don't even
necessarily think that bars are a bad
place to meet women i think it's just
the type of bar
so
like i think a club i really wouldn't
recommend but like a laid-back bar with
music
you can be a normal person and go out
you know
um yeah grocery store too
um
you might starbucks that's a good one
too starbucks
you play basketball yes
at what age does not ever having a
long-term relationship become a red flag
for women or for men
um
oh gosh i
for me the question is why like why have
they never had a long-term relationship
um
i think as a guy oh gosh
if it's gonna make the girl lose
attraction to you if
you're over 25 and you've never had one
to be on i'm just you know being honest
unless oh my gosh this is so bad but
unless you're good looking because then
the girl will assume
it's because
um no i'm sorry i'm thinking this out
loud
yeah the question is why like it depends
if the girl assumes
that you could have had a long-term
relationship but you just chose not to
have one but if the girl assumes that
the reason you haven't had one is
because you couldn't have had one like
i think that's more when it's gonna
bother them
um
[Music]
for girls
maybe over
25.
um
what's a good way to approach a girl in
person
that i find respectful
um
i'm pretty laid back so i think just
introducing yourself is a good way
to meet women actually you know it's
another place to meet women
um is church their women always
outnumber the men in church the issue
is that does not guarantee that she's
gonna be like a good girl and that's
where men go wrong as they think
oh i met her in church she's not
involved in any of that stuff
not true um but the ratio is at least in
your favor like
you know if there's three men or women
to every one man like isn't that a good
place room to be in
he spent his youth caring for his sickly
parents
yeah that's not a bad that's like that's
attractive
um
i'm not making anything i told my mom
i'd chop up vegetables for her for later
so that's what i'm doing
okay wait
but my mom's making fajitas later
i think i'm doing this wrong because
this is taking up so much time and i
feel like it shouldn't
but i guess that gives you guys more q a
right so good for you
how does it feel to be back home oh my
gosh it's been so nice i love hanging
out with my siblings
and my parents
i love i love being home
so
i can't wait
um
i'm hungry i kinda wanna make a smoothie
favorite movie genre i like dramas
how do i cut onions cold or hot are at
room temperature um my mom
oh gosh i don't really like onions so i
don't cut them often
i want to make a smoothie
do you have any family traditions we
have a lot of family traditions
um like we all get nutcrackers every
year
okay hold up
so
no i haven't watched spiderman i don't
really like movies
i don't like onions i know
am i a gang member no
oh my gosh okay
i need a real knife please get a knife
was this not a real knife
should i try this one
they don't like onions red flag
oh you're right
oh wow
what was i doing
oh wow
oh this still isn't a real knife
on earth
a shell snipe what's a chef's knife
oh my god i have no idea
this
oh my gosh
oh no i don't like cutting without
no oh my gosh guys i don't know
i'm almost done with these anyway so
next i cut onions
okay oh someone asked a question
um someone said what are common themes
you've noticed about talking to other
women about
red pill um
[Music]
probably that when i say that men have
it hard a lot of women's first like gut
reaction is
well so do women
that's kind of annoying
okay ladies we're not talking about us
right now
like can we get this to them we talk
about us all the time
okay what about this knife
i know that's the same one as before
this one maybe this one's like
more jaded
okay
have you ever
have have you ever a ring stuck on your
finger
had a guy buy me a ring before
i need a chopper with a chopper
can you guys tell i can't cook
in my home i'm at my parents
denver house or breckenridge is where
it's at
so
um i don't i don't hear about that i
don't know who
i don't know how to say his name hassan
is i don't know who that is
i don't really go on twitch
so
uh
ugh
oh my god what is that i don't know what
that's doing
okay wait my uncle
um did i say see jake paul knockout tyra
yeah i saw a clip
um my uncle
always told me that breckenridge and the
front ridge are kind of closed off in
the winter due to the snow i guess it
wasn't true rip um some of the parts are
closed off some parts of the park um
would i ever marry a man for his
personality and nothing else no i think
character is important so
it's not always about money
it's not always about personality either
you can have a great personality but if
you don't have drive ambition work ethic
or character it doesn't matter
um
okay
um
the fight was fake um i didn't seem fake
to me but i don't know anything about
boxing
oh my god i don't know how to cut onions
i don't what is my mom
oh no i'm not even done with the peppers
i thought i was done
uh
no loyalty
who should i be loyal to i'm confused
um
who's my celebrity crush
oh my gosh my ex-boyfriend got so mad at
me for saying this oh my god he like
would not talk to me for days
when i was asked in an interview who my
celebrity crush was
and i said it was jesse williams
and then he was so mad oh my god he was
so mad
who
who it's um
jesse williams is
he's on grey's anatomy
i also had a taylor lautner phase when i
was a kid
you would have guessed trevor noah
trevino trevor noah is cute and he is
cute i'm not even gonna lie um
i remember you were a twilight girl
do i plan
on talking to uk guys oh yeah i'm
definitely gonna collab with uk um
content creators
yes i want to get in touch with jessica
x but she has not responded to me um
i'll probably try to meet up with zubi
if i can with um
sarah garvey
um
there's a girl that was on my live
earlier i
will probably
connect with while i'm there
for fajitas cut strips up and down
without the roots facing away from me
okay
oh wow
oh is this how i'm supposed to cut them
no
[Music]
i've been doing it wrong the whole time
i was given no instructions
by my mother i was just told to cut
that would have saved me a lot of time
but
okay
wait okay okay
um
sir you're gonna get banned soon
i don't really care
what beliefs you have
um
but don't
don't put that on me
like i'm just living my life
don't don't be mad just because
i don't
um
am i still in the uk no i live there but
i'm home right now okay i don't know how
to chop onions
this will be a learning experience on
the live
i'm assuming this like outer part comes
off
have i watched patrice o'neal a little
bit
so
i'm just chopping them in squares
i have no idea if that's right
anyone say
don't project your excuses
on to me
um
it's not really an excuse
look at god picked favorites
and being his favorite i'm in the
position where
get to pick a guy because i like him and
i'm attracted to him because
i don't the only man i mooch off of is
my father
that's it
so
yeah
you guys
can chill
um i am god's favorite oh my god
one i was born in the best country in
the world
two
two
i get to travel pretty much anywhere
i want with my family who is amazing and
i love
and on top of that
i have nine siblings i don't even need
friends
my parents support me and whatever i
choose to do
i'm also christian so
it's actually i literally like
sorry
um okay let's
see um was i born and walk kayak i don't
even know
oh my god my eyes my eyes are watering
okay i don't know what this is beeping
for
oh
huh
sir
come on the internet are so weird
cut out the root i don't know what the
root is
i don't know
oh god oh god
the root is gone what did i do something
wrong
oh no is my mom gonna kill me
[Music]
okay well
hmm
does your parents adopt adults they've
adopted some 17 year olds and 18 year
olds but no
actually oh my god oh my god my eyes my
eyes
i also have very sensitive eyes to be
honest
is my mom gonna kill me
open the window
i could oh my god my eyes
okay
oh my god
okay first i'm gonna take off the outer
layer i think
and then second
oh my god
oh my gosh
ah
no guys i'm not a wimp i will continue
oh god
all right why does that thing keep
beeping i unplugged it
um
guys oh my gosh
i really don't care about some weird guy
behind a computer in the chat um
so i've realized a lot of times the
people that are the most like
aggressive
are usually like the people that are the
most unhappy with their life
so
i just let them do them
and i'll probably get a moderator at
some point but
i think i might have one or two but i
don't live stream enough to care
oh gosh
um
oh
man okay
okay next we got chicken i'm done with
the vegetables
because i think that's enough
eh
[Applause]
okay sorry
okay chicken is next
all right
okay i should
should bring you guys back a little more
see better i didn't realize my head was
being cut off
um
okay guys add more questions in the chat
i like answering questions while i do
stuff
what am i making my mom's making fajitas
tonight she just asked me to cut up
stuff so
here i
am i heard this knife will be better
yeah i went to elmhurst college
am i planning on staying in the uk
um i think i'd consider staying in the
uk if i met a guy in the uk but outside
of that then no
oh wow this knife is a lot better
so
so
okay
um abba says a lot of america
women women think that the average life
with that and the
a man is unattractive is that crazy or
do you agree with him
um
i've seen a lot of stuff on the internet
that indicates that
but
i don't know i've seen a lot of girls
date just normal average guys
probably guys that are better looking
than them maybe but like
um
i would say
it's probably with women that don't have
much going on
um
[Music]
i thought i had a boyfriend um i i was
dating one yay but we broke up a couple
weeks ago
when did i start creating
content in the manosphere um probably
about a year ago
maybe a little less probably six months
ago um
maybe february of last year almost a
year
it's my first kevin samuels reaction
video
uh
um
um have i ever tried african food no but
i'd like to
sounds good
i would
um okay
oh my god there's so much chicken
it's a little further back maybe
okay
cut against the grain okay oh wow
sir you've been teaching me more
about chopping that i've learned in my
life
oh wow
that definitely helped
oh my goodness
um okay wait what did it say do you
think the manosphere talking points are
unhinged from real life or accurate to
real life um i definitely think they're
accurate to real life but i think if you
get
if you're involved in a certain world
those truths don't matter as much to you
um
but no there's definitely a lot of truth
to a lot of the manosphere talking
plants
but
okay
um
um
since
since creating content for the man of
sphere have you learned anything that
you don't already know
oh yes
um
yes i would say
a thousand percent yes
um for example
i never really realized how much age gap
dating is like a thing
um it's never really been a thing in my
world most of my friends date guys
within
five years of how old they are but it's
something i never really like thought
about i guess
um
some of the points seem exaggerated as
woman dates all types of weird dudes i
don't think dating in real life is that
hard
um
i think dating i think relationships are
hard
i'm not a fan of a lot of the hypocrisy
in the manosphere um
i'm just personally i would never
expect something from someone that i
couldn't do um i think it's like nice in
theory
and online but i don't think that works
well in relationships
a lot of
like a lot of stuff that
the red pill promotes i think again
works well in
theory but you know
relationships
yeah relationships are work
and
yeah
oh my god why is there so much chicken
i'm so tired of doing this
um you still date one yay no i don't
date one yay
and also
life throws so many curveballs at you it
really just matters
the type of person that you date like
the person you choose to marry is
someone you're going to have to be
around until you're literally 70.
if it works out
so
as much as money status game all that
[ __ ] helps like at the end of the day
you just want someone that
you want to be around until you're 70.
so
um
i think the most reputable person in the
manosphere is kevin samuels i think he
lives out what he says he lives out
i think his advice is the most practical
and makes the most sense
um
i'm trying to think
all right
i think a lot of guys learned game in
these like big cities and
i i don't think that's necessarily
the real world
um
okay
best gift i got with my ex-boyfriend i
would 100 go live with rolo um
i've tried to set up
lives with him but he's never responded
um
but i totally would
um
who
what was the best gift i ever got um
i don't know maybe he got me some
diamonds
he got me a pair of shoes actually that
was really nice
um
i don't think 1y
would have been
high value technically
um
but would i date another one sure
rolo tomasi is live
[Music]
no i don't think
he doesn't have like a collin show
oh 22
thank you who
donated why can't i see the super chat
and get a real knife thank you
um
okay live chat
um
at what point do in a man boys lives do
you think red point is relevant
um
i think it's relevant
depending on how good you are with girls
i don't think guys that are good with
girls like need it to be honest
um
[Music]
no he didn't have all the high value man
traits if we're gonna be technical um
because
you have to be over a certain age and
you have to have made the money for a
certain amount of years
um and you have to have a network
so
no but
um do you think people put effort in
gifts or does it not matter i think it
depends on what the person you're dating
values so i'm not really a gift person
like that stuff doesn't matter
i care more about like
um
acts of service
um
okay
but i don't really care if a guy is high
value because
i it's like a bonus but
it's not
it's not everything
um
i'm kind of confused by some red pill
advice it says focus on yourself
women come later but you also need to
get experience
i think it's more
become successful and the women will
come
and
get experience where you can
but the focus should be on becoming as
successful as possible
in all areas of life including the gym
the
work
game if you can but i think red pill
well
i i don't think the focus of red pill is
game
um
okay i'm almost done
um
i'm not gonna lie i don't really care
about
success i'm fine being a regular dude
okay well then
don't be mad when you attract regular
women
like
that's fine if that's what you want just
don't be mad about the outcome
um okay two more pieces of chicken and
i'm done
thank god okay hold on
dang you shopping at oof not really
um okay
oh my gosh i'm almost done
i have one more piece of chicken left
after this one
um
am i going to be a live stream
am i going to do a live stream with
donovan sharp yeah um i think i'm doing
a show with him
on his channel
um starting the 16th on thursday nights
something like that
am i studying in the uk yes
okay
yes
oh thank god oh no oh no no no
okay
um what do i think of the future
yo i've been preached lied about
receiving the letter from youtube
okay um
send me that i guess so you know you say
you followed
kevin samuel's advice with angry
reactions i don't know what that means
what do i see as the future of the
dating market um
[Music]
okay this is not based on data but i
think at some point there will be a
reset
where
women are going to be brought down to
earth because
they need a guy
and i do think that at some point women
will be brought down to earth
when i was oh when i was on a show
oh i guess i did technically
i forgot i went on his show
that was so long ago
oh there there's
a lot of
ah
why didn't i just burn the trash here
that would have made so much more sense
okay
[Music]
okay
okay
okay
i'm hungry now but i can't eat it
um
women look way hotter when they say i
need a man
um
i think it's just like a humility thing
oh my gosh i could not live without my
sibling oh this is what keeps running
the fridge is open
oh my gosh hold up
[Music]
oh my gosh
um
[Music]
oftentimes girls will say i need a
boyfriend
am i single by choice
i know what
wendy and i just broke up a little bit
ago
so it really hasn't been that long
um my siblings went out skiing i didn't
feel like going today
hold on
[Music]
but not all the siblings are here
actually
so
hold on
tells us
after a black guy tell us do they go
back or was dawn of it
right
um
i i don't know i haven't
it's
okay um
why i can't work out with one yay um i
just see our backgrounds as being a
little bit too different um
i think if your relationship gets to a
point where you're just
fighting all the time i don't
think it's a good idea to stay in it i
felt like i was the only one
compromising
and i was just like
giving and giving and giving and just
like by the end of that relationship i
literally felt like i had nothing else
to give
honestly yeah
so i'm not trying to like say too much
or whatever but
um hold on
i'm hungry what i want to eat
i don't know that's why i say it's not
always about money people always make it
just about money
um
oh gosh why is this
doing that okay oh god oh god
um
i think i want to make a smoothie
um
i already had a smoothie today
we have in the kitchen
[Music]
i'm in the pantry
[Music]
a um of junk in here
foreign
good luck with volleyball thank you
okay guys well
i'm done cooking
um
[Music]
you guys got any more questions
sharp from no jumper i don't know who
that is
encore
what do you guys want what do you what
questions you got
i don't know why
i can't see the chat consistently it
kind of annoys me
oh gosh
kill mary smash
um
oh gosh
um you guys have to super chat me if you
want me to answer that question
um would i ever be in an open
relationship no
um
gray
tux
i said graysuit
oh no
um
what veggies i was chopping up peppers
and onions and chicken
um
what is my take on donovan sharp
clapping back at the lead attorney
i don't think i watched it fully
but the lead attorney had a very
convincing case so i would be very
surprised
if he sounded more credible than a
20-year divorce attorney
but
you tell me i don't think i watched that
one
okay i'm getting ice cream
um
[Applause]
um
i think brittany renner will probably
end up alone
um not because she couldn't date someone
but because
i don't know if she has the skills to
maintain a healthy relationship
most offensive
word for a white person
i don't know
cracker maybe but i wouldn't really care
so
back
um
guys if you want me to answer a juicy
question
you have to super chat
sorry i'm just letting you know
you want me to answer someone
have i met my weight loss goal yet why
do you have to ask me that
when i'm eating ice cream
why are you gonna call me out like that
um
no i'm getting there though i'm seven
pounds down
so i'm getting closer i have like
like 10 to go that i want to do
do you think donovan sharp is a high
value man i don't know how much he makes
um
what's my rent oh my god too much it's a
thousand three hundred pounds which is
like 1700
us dollars
a super chat it's like a donation
so if you want me to answer like a juicy
question i'm not doing that for free
sorry like
i'll answer pg questions but
but like
f mary kill no i'm not doing that for
for you
um
do you think russell wilson is a samp
um
um
yeah probably a little bit
um
do you believe high value man is based
on character or financial status um i
think it starts with financial status
but you can't be a high value man
without character
um do male marathoners and cyclists seem
wimpy to women
um
i mean yeah i mean cycling is not
exactly an attractive sport like
i don't think we're
turned on by cyclists
but if if you're doing like crazy
cycling like the discipline is
attractive i would say
someone asked me earlier about a guy
having not having social media and you
said it was attractive if the reason is
because he was taking care of his sickly
parents um okay no that's not what i
said
i said that having no social media is
attractive
if
like the reason isn't because you're
like a loser
like if you don't have social media
because you choose not to like then it's
attractive um
you will always emasculate your future
man by comparing them to your father men
hate that probably i love my dad he'll
just have to deal with that
high value man is all based on income no
it starts with an income
that's what it starts with
it's not all based on income
so
women like men who are dangerous men
like women who are vulnerable
i guess yeah i guess men do like a
damsel in distress don't they
did i ban the hater no he got bored as
they do
how much of my viewing audience is women
i could tell you it's like 50 percent
i'll show you my analytics
um let's say the last
last seven seven days
50 50 50 male 50 female
[Music]
how many women do you think are
delusional
oh gosh maybe 50
do you have a manager yeah he takes like
28
of my cut
you would have bet money is just guys
nope
oh gosh
um
how many guys do i think are delusional
um
maybe like 30 percent
what's your cognitive disability can you
hide it
um
am i a fan of game of thrones no i've
never seen it i've maybe seen one
episode but nothing
crazy
um
hey
is your laundry done
you're basically blind in your left eye
um
i mean i don't think it's like a bad
thing
to tell so i don't think that won't make
too much of a difference
okay react to the channel feminine
perspective feminine
i can't show it to you on the screen
because i only have
my phones here
but
what what video
let's see
hi friends welcome back so i want to
talk in today's video
about height and why i think girls
should not be so obsessed with hype it's
one of those things where i feel really
bad for guys because obviously
the height they are is something that's
genetic and it's something they cannot
change
so
whereas the girl can
lose weight or do different things or
dye her hair maybe to change her
appearance
for a guy
he's unfortunately set at the height
that he is and i feel that a lot of
possibly resentment from guys um
can i fake a british accent not yet
um why don't girls want to date the
short guys why didn't man always come
back hi everyone
12 minutes
guys is there like a five minute video i
could watch
[Music]
um
let's see
um
so rough with my phone i know i left all
my equipment in the uk it just was not
worth
bringing back i guess
can everything be done on your phone
then
you're only wishing it could be oh
um
somewhat like
it's like a walmart version of youtube i
would say like i can do it it's just
like a much lower quality
like filming on my
phone camera versus like my canon or
like reacting to a video on my second
phone versus
i gotcha yeah
so they're asking me to react to this
other channel but i can't show them the
screen because i don't have a pc here
do you need to use mine
no because
you'd have to
it's like more work than it's worth i'd
have to download like a software and
like like hook up it's
because i have a laptop but again it's
like
because then you have to use your camera
on the laptop which is usually pretty
shitty or you hook it you have to
download software to hook it up to a
camera right and i'm like nah i'll just
do low quality content until i get back
to europe so it's not a big deal
it's only three weeks it's not the end
what's the walmart for the one percent
i don't know
we still go to walmart so
yep
i think more rich people go to
walmart than you would think
really well not even walmart i just the
cheapest the richest people i know are
always the cheapest for whatever reason
it seems like there's some truth to that
like my dad always drove to colorado
oh wow yeah instead of flying to save
money i'm like i'm like dad why don't
you value your time at all
he doesn't
say he's going to fix something that's
going to take forever
to do that that's what that's what i
tell him
i'm like dad
you could just like pay someone he's
like that's how i stay rich and i'm like
dad no it's not
it's literally not like i guarantee the
money you've saved on flights on the
over the years has not made you rich
like i guarantee it is not
but
that's just
my cash app oh my god yes i will drop my
cash up
don't be you guys always cap you always
cap that you're gonna send me money
so if you're capping i'm gonna be
i'm gonna be okay i'll be fine to be
honest but
i'll be disappointed my cash app is
hannah pearl davis
h-a-n-n-a-h p-e-a-r-l-d-a-b-i-s
let's see come on are you capping i'm
waiting
oh my goodness
so if you comment on these things will
you get a small
amount of money then
oh they can send donations
type it
here
this this is my cash app
so it's like a live stream so they just
put stuff in the chat and i can just
like respond
um
i don't know if i can type it on my
phone oh you know what i'll do it on my
other phone i'll type it
um
and then whose channel is it that you're
watching on youtube
oh it's mine
yeah it's called just pearly things okay
so sometimes i'll just live stream when
i'm bored
and normally i can like
do it to content and stuff but
no
oh here jack called me a little bit just
about 15 minutes ago
just resting and doing some laundry and
i said vegetables let me know if there's
anything else
you didn't see there was you guys
checked it out
see what you said
okay
how many students were at my college it
was like five thousand maybe it was
pretty small okay yeah that's kind of a
small area not terribly it's not
terribly small but smaller
um house tour i'll probably do one
i'll probably do one at some point but i
kind of want to do it before we left
because it'll be clean
uh okay sir you're gonna get blocked
um
would i ever date a co-worker
um
well i'm on youtube so
um
i wanted to once but he didn't like me
so
but other than that no i've never dated
a co-worker
um
honestly a smaller school sounds better
it just depends what you want i was an
athlete so i liked it but
i don't know if the average person would
have preferred a small school
because
there's a lot to do if you're an athlete
but
if you're not like it just depends what
you like
okay wait
all i say about
about
my body count is that it's under 10
that's the only thing that i say
actually i don't even i really should
just not answer that question on the
internet
um
because it's just like awkward like you
answer one and then people be like who
and then it just doesn't stop
um
meet me live stream
no i've never
done that
um
a favorite female comedian
um
i don't really like any female comedians
oh my god someone actually sent me money
thank you justin
thank you
i did not expect that to pan out
what's an acceptable number of bodies
for a guy to have for you
um
i don't care
like
under
30 maybe 40
but it depends on his age so
um
people make a lot of money live
streaming on there
uh
do you find no low numbers for guys
suspicious uh not really
um
is 100 a high body count yes that's
super high
um has it started snowing in london yet
um
no it hasn't last time i was there
you're 38
um i guess that's not bad if you're 38
but i don't really
i don't really care about that stuff
um i'd say the higher it is i'm gonna be
like more intimidated but like i don't
really care
um a body count of one is too high if
the woman is not married
uh okay
remove your ex's videos from your
channel and then a result pulsed by that
i will at some point i just haven't
really felt like going through it
so but i will i definitely will
all body counters is really comparing
and to be honest you can't
like you can't change your body count
as a guy or a girl
you can just like do the best you can
so you're really just comparing yourself
to other people and that's what a lot of
the manosphere is it's like comparing
yourself
to other people in terms of like money
height status et cetera um
but it's a lot of [ __ ] that like you
can't change and it's a lot of [ __ ] you
can
um so like wait i guess money you can
change but
like age for women
status for men beta alpha like you can't
really change your personality
so
like focusing on it isn't really going
to do much
the veggies are in the fridge
if a guy has a lower body count then use
it weird um
no i don't care about that stuff
no that's not
why a man wants a virgin it's about
comparing yourself to other men you're
lacking you're making an excuse to let
dismiss your lack of purity
um
no i think it's perfectly fine to want a
virgin i like actually if i could do it
all over again
that's like probably how i would do it
but i can't so i can't like go back
but i definitely i know i have a low
body count compared to most girls
nowadays
um
so
because again at the end of the day
you can't change
anything um
same thing with age you can't really
change that so you just do the best best
with what you can
um
you argue with everything that's a
criticism against you uh no i don't
um
okay how do as a girl how do you change
your age
you can't
like
and this is coming i'm 25 i'm not even
in the like danger zone but i still
can't change my age
um
am i doing another ig live next weekend
um maybe
probably
i'll do a lot of lives this week so i'm
just doing everything off of my phone
um
reactive female dating strategies can
you dm that to me because maybe i will
when i get back
um you are a fundamentally dishonest
person
so you don't know me um
now you create a straw man if you can't
change your age so you can't change
anything
no no that's not what i said that's not
oh my goodness sometimes i feel like i'm
arguing with the dumbest people in the
comments section
what i'm saying is there are things that
you can change and they're things that
you can't as i said before there are
things that men cannot change such as
height
the way their face looks okay
um
and there are things that women can't
change age body count
they can't change that but they can make
changes going forward
and what i'm saying is you can't worry
about [ __ ] that's happened in the past
because
you literally can't change it so the
only thing you can do is make the best
of your situation going forward
so i don't know why that's a crazy
statement
and do the best you can even with a guy
like if you're working hard and doing
the best you can when it comes
to income
like that's all you can do is do the
best you can
have i taken the 15 personality test
i did on a live
um
okay
you paul r you'll have to pay me for
that question i'm not gonna lie to you
oh my goodness
um
i'm not a christian okay i don't care um
do you think fresh and fit will lose
their youtube channel after all the mass
flagging of their content creators
videos no i think youtube wants to make
money off them they'll get like a slap
on the wrist
is broccoli the best vegetable no i
don't like broccoli
there are tree buttons you can ban him
[Music]
i kind of like to give critics
their time of day because i don't really
shy away from criticism
um
but
yeah if he gets too bad i probably will
like teddy roosevelt said comparison is
the thief of joy i can't change my
personality but i can add to it yes
yes that's exactly what i'm saying is
there is [ __ ] you cannot change
so why on earth
um
so you're in a relationship with someone
and before getting intimate they tell
you they have an std that would be a
deal breaker for me
um
it's funny all you do is argue it's
funny because if i take a personality
test then i'm on the 70th 70th
percentile for agreeableness
so i'm actually more agreeable than
disagreeable
fun fact
um paul r oh you really sent me a super
chat would i go down on a guy who
refuses to down on you um
yeah i would
i have
um
but it's kind of funny because i really
think the way it's supposed to be is
you're supposed to wait until you're
married like i don't think we're
supposed to have
all these like soul ties and stuff like
i don't think that's the way it's
supposed to be
but
it's just
it's kind of
weird 2021 i don't know
um
[Music]
what pearl what do you think about
plastic surgery and boob jobs on women
um i think that
there's a price for everything
and i'm not necessarily against plastic
surgery but i think there's a point
where like
it just looks really fake
um
the best way to see if someone is a good
person um i would say their actions and
the way they treat people and their
ability to have close relationships
so
you can go to church and be an [ __ ]
to everyone but you can't really fake
close and intimate relationships and
people that care about you
you also can't fake how you spend your
free time and your money
so i'd say that's the best way to
look at it
have i done any paid collabs um not on
youtube i've done some collabs on tick
tock like brand deals but not on youtube
[Music]
collab with andrew tate i'd like to
um how much for a brand for parade
promos am i open to doing paid collabs
on youtube yes i totally am
i just haven't like spent a lot of time
pursuing them
um no i don't think atheists are
horrible people
um i probably wouldn't say a rate on a
live but if you want to dm me on
instagram that's like where i do most of
my
like messaging with brands and stuff
are there any strong points
in the red pill that almost like pillars
that you disagree with oh that's a
really good question
[Music]
strong points
[Music]
i don't know oh that's a really good
question
um maybe i'm not as
my friend that interviewed while driving
doing um what friend i've interviewed a
decent amount of people while driving
does race matter or height more be
truthful um
[Music]
i would say height
more
this is a high value oh yeah i know
that's one
high value man don't cheat they have
options yeah i would agree with that
actually
um who's my favorite comedian maybe dave
chappelle but i'm not that into
comedians
is cheating a deal breaker uh yes
but everyone has a line on what they
think cheating is
and to me
like i don't think flirt like i wouldn't
break up with a guy for flirting with a
girl but like
i don't know what the line is but
um am i back home
yeah i'm back home for christmas
um who do i think is more of a fraud
between myron and fresh
um
i would say i would think
uh i would actually say that i think
fresh gets more girls than myren i don't
know why
so if we're going
who gets more girls i guess him um
what do you think it says about american
society that so many young men failed to
learn how to be men
um that men weren't in the household
probably
how's the uk compared to the states um
i would say the uk
it's very it's more similar than
i thought to be honest
um the british accents are cool i would
say it's a little bit more liberal than
the states at least where i'm from
um what i did again with kids i guess i
can't say i wouldn't because i have so
i mean i think the preference is no kids
but
uh no i think depression is real but i
think a lot of times it's overblown here
but
like i think a lot of people claim
depression that don't have depression
but i would say that it is real
[Music]
what is dating like for me
um
oh my gosh well it's
i mean i i've met i was in a
relationship the past year
and before then i really
didn't date anyone for two years
because i was sad over a guy that i
wasted like
oh my god years with so
um so i really feel like i haven't been
in the dating game too much
um
what values do you look for in a guy
that you will absolutely not waver on
um i want to say that dating i think is
like different than marrying because
i've definitely like
dated
a guy that maybe didn't have all the
traits that i'm looking for but that's
you know why it didn't work out
um
for me the biggest thing is like work
ethic
um and that is very different than money
and people confuse
those all the time
but i i cannot stand lazy like sitting
around all day doing nothing it drives
me crazy
so i would say
work ethic is the number one thing that
i would not waver on
um also
like honesty
so
um
yeah honesty and work ethic
you're uploading a video exposing me
okay
um would i split bills with a guy uh
yeah i would
um
turquoise is probably my favorite color
um
um
so
sir i'm waiting i'm kind of excited my
first expose video i'm so excited for
this
would i ever dated guy that works 80
hours a week yes i would um
i'm so excited
i've always wanted an exposing video
you'll always know that you've made it
when you get cancelled i'm so excited
um
when's the last time you've been to the
movies oh god i don't remember
over a year i don't know i don't really
like movies
um do i think red pill will ever go
mainstream uh stream
um
[Music]
no
well i remember you when
we i get famous i know
just be honest no
did i just admit that i look forward to
getting cancelled
yeah because the second you get
cancelled you know you're making money
they do not cancel people that nobody's
ever heard of so if you're big enough to
get cancelled you are doing something
right yeah i'm kind of excited for the
day is that
is that wrong
what's that
come on
you'll protest outside the oscars when i
get cancelled oh my gosh i'm not an
actress
but yeah go ahead
you're loyal
sir i'm waiting for my exposing video
where is it
i'm so excited
uh
just pearly things exposed
okay i'm excited where is it
just pearly things
exposed look
so let us go ahead and discuss
the 10 signs then you start
um
damn
no exposed
i hate it
when i promise something and it doesn't
come through
i was told as we speak that there was an
exposure video coming out
that's just hurtful you know
okay
um
i think it'll be a while look at you
never know i talk a lot
people that talk a lot say a lot of dumb
[ __ ]
and at some point i'm sure i've said
dumb [ __ ] i would not put it past me
um
ever been in new york city uh yes
uh
perfect
um why am i coming out with nfts i don't
think i'm big enough to like need an nft
uh i'm a center in basketball i'm a
middle and volleyball
i did used to have braces now i don't
they didn't help me fix what i was
trying to fix which is my jaw
that's what i was trying to fix but it
didn't help
um
when i was younger and i was dating i
always said that i wanted someone
taller than me the same politics same
religion
a hard worker
i think that was it i think those are
the four things that i used to say when
i was younger
so it's funny because i never even
thought about a minimum income
requirement until the red pill started
like um
if i could meet anyone in history um i'd
meet amelia earhart and ask her how she
died because
that question has been
on my head in my mind for years
for real years
um i'm six foot in basketball so i was a
little bit short but
what what else are you gonna do
oh yay you're uploading 60 done
i'm i'm really excited for this
ugh
[Music]
hmm
how can you impress me what does that
even mean
um
i'm really not like
like i just
got out of a relationship
so
i'm like in therapy right now to be
honest
um
they solved amelia earhart how'd she die
you're too crashed and died but they
never found her plane and then they were
saying that like she maybe landed on an
island
i don't know i just
these questions kill me
therapy is for quitters
um i think therapy forever is for
quitters but therapy for a couple months
i think actually is good
would i be willing to debate yeah i
don't disagree with too much
of the mana sphere so i think it'd
depend
okay tell me why
okay tell me
um
because a lot of stuff
like i don't even think i just i think
people think i disagree more than i do
amelia earhart are you kidding me
like the first woman to fly
mom dad
i can't even defend my honor
you seem like an incel i'm not even
gonna lie to you
but okay
let me know i hope this is a good video
i really do i'm gonna be so mad
did amelia have a dream
um no i never received a copyright from
fresh and fit
i'm so excited my first hate video
your last
i'm so excited
um
hey
therapy is for [ __ ] fam what i don't
know what that means
um no i'm going to therapy because
um
there was a lot of stuff that went on in
that relationship that
was traumatic so
that is why i'm in therapy
um
what did you consider the be the biggest
contributing factor to men's present-day
frustrations with the dating market
or do you feel like it's exaggerated
that's a good question
i don't think it's exaggerated per se
um
i think that
that'd be kind of a funny youtube video
an exorcism
um like
decided to get exercise
okay um
i would say the biggest factor is social
media i think that it's really bad for
relationships both men male and female
um
but i guess i can't really
what do they say attack the hand that
feeds you because i you literally use
social media
okay guys sir i'm waiting on this
hate video i'm really excited
i'm really excited for it
i i think that
it's gonna be
pretty cool like i'm
i'm starting to think it doesn't exist
i'm not gonna lie to you
ain't nothing but a heartache
tell me why ain't nothing but a mistake
tell me why i'm never gonna hear you say
yeah i
want it that way
i'm getting tired
maybe this will generate a buzz i doubt
it because
i'm looking at your channel and your
last video got five views
so it could you never know
but
i'm just saying like odds are probably
not
i for real need a haircut so bad though
hi
i can sing a little bit
i
want it that way
tell me why ain't nothing but a mistake
tell me a little bit
um
i thought
like
i could tell all the people from this
live to go and get you more views
it would be i'm a person
endo started shortening it
if you're just in a relate
sometimes i was planning sometimes
okay sir
oh this is an interesting live actually
the
lead attorney
ain't nothing but a mistake
[Music]
i
want it that way
you know you don't have to open my door
you know yadda yadda
okay
i don't care i'm 48 years old there
should be people out here that's the
same age as me which i've met that would
want to do the same thing
what do i think could make red pill
become mainstream nothing
because
um i think you need to sell stuff to
women to make money
if i had um hours to live how would i
spend my day
um
probably with my family
did i not see that the lead attorney
video about
um
okay guys i gotta go
um i'm kind of bummed because i was
hoping to react to my first hate video
and exposed video live but
it did not
happen that way
but i'm gonna talk to you guys later
thank you thanks for the donations bye